miles Garrett has been reinstated by the
National Football League just two days
after meeting with the league executives
including Commissioner Roger Goodell
Andrew berry the new GM of the Browns
welcome miles back in a statement issued
by the team we welcome them back with
open arms we know he's grateful to be
reinstated eager to put the past behind
him and continue to evolve and grow as a
leader we look forward to having his
strong positive presence back as a
teammate player and person in our
community that's all well and good but
here's the bottom line the guy did
something Shareen we had never seen
before I was horrified by it
removing the helmet of a opposing player
and whacking him over the head with it
in a windmill motion that should have
knocked him out the most amazing aspect
of the entire incident was that Mason
Rudolph was not knocked out called by
what miles Garrett did and that's good
it's good wasn't seriously injured but
as you're welcome miles Garrett back you
better be darn sure that whatever fuse
blew for him to cause him to do that to
Rudolph is never gonna happen again
because the next time it happens they
may not be as lucky as they were the
first time yeah absolutely and you knew
this reinstatement was coming when they
let him back in the building late last
season and he started training in
Cleveland again and and you know he
served his Senate six games and I guess
they are confident that he's not gonna
do this again that he's not gonna lose
his cool I know this kid really well and
it you know it was out of character for
him to do this but he did it and he's
paid a price and he better not do it
again or he's gonna be out of the league
you know he's already got that new dama
cansu label on him and he'll wear that
for the rest of his career there's
nothing he can do from now on that's
gonna erase what happened on in that
moment that heated moment and it didn't
take long and it didn't last long but
he's never gonna live that down yeah I
mean I'd like to think that the NFL has
done a full and complete psychological
workup to come to the conclusion that
this won't happen again I really do
think it was more of an effort to
impress upon Miles Garrett that if it
does happen again you're done you're not
coming back and that's that
I don't think there's any way they can
be sure he's never gonna do it again and
the fact that he's already done it once
that's the thing oh oh he would never do
anything like that well he already did
he already did they can't act surprised
if it happens again and it's more than
just any liability they would have to a
player who is seriously injured or worse
if he does it again if it happens again
and if there is a serious injury that's
inflicted because of it it hurts the
game in immeasurable ways that's why
they need to be certain that he's gotten
the message that he's going to restrain
himself and that if there's anything
even close to this in the future right
not just something clearly after the
whistle where the helmet was removed and
the guy's whacked over the head with it
but any kind of extracurricular stuff
that you know he'd been fine for a
couple of times I'm not saying he's on a
one strike and you're out arrangement
there but they need to be watching
everything he does and they need to be
ready to intervene aggressively Shirine
if there's anything that would be
finable or suspended well and he has to
know that too his every move is gonna be
watched and if he hits a quarterback
even a little bit late he's gonna be
penalized and he's probably gonna be
fine I mean this is a stain that's not
going to go away the officials are gonna
know about it his opponents are gonna go
know about it and they're going to be
trying to bait him I guarantee you they
will try to bait him to get him to do
something to get a 15-yard penalty and
he did have a number of penalties mostly
for late hits the quarterbacks but he's
got to tone it down and find a way to
make that aggressiveness work for him
and not work against him which we've
seen way too many times in his career so
far and you're absolutely right this
stuff I look it there's still a debate
over what it is that he heard that
caused him to blow the gasket the first
time around he's going to be hearing all
kinds of stuff and I remember Tony Dungy
saying back when this happened you have
that that's football you hear everything
you hear anything and everything because
they are trying to get you to lose your
cool and once you have shown that you
are a guy who will lose your cool that's
when you're going to get it even more I
mean there's a lot of stuff that gets
sanitized and they don't have
microphones on all the players or
at least when they do they don't have
them live and hot so we can hear what
they're saying but yeah he's gonna get
it even more aggressively and he's been
he's gonna have to be ready for that and
he's gonna have to find that balance
between what's acceptable and what's not
while he's being baited in a way he's
never been baited before and as good as
he's been with 30.5 Sachs in his career
so far that's been the biggest knock on
him has been those penalties in finding
a way to use that aggressiveness to his
advantage he hasn't done that so far
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports